I have to admit I was hoping that Gracie
would be here with you today but when
you get to share like job moments like
this being the big sister I mean you do
movies like this kind of for her yeah I
do but I also I also just enjoy doing
family-friendly movies you know it makes
me feel good to make people happy and
you know everything going on so it just
it's it's fun but of course yes a big
reason is my sister you may just wait
five years for rare but we got it now
why was this the perfect time to release
you know five years after revive yeah it
just didn't feel right before I I wanted
to make something that was transparent
yet really classy and very real to me so
I just I guess this was the right time
and I felt it so it's crazy you know
what I'm feeling I'm feeling dance again
come on now feels so good take it so
many ways what went into your thinking
in that song as you said it feels good
to just dance again yeah I think that
the whole objective of the album is
self-love and acceptance and that's
something that I think I don't know that
song makes me feel like I got my step
back and I feel like alright I'm back in
the game a bit it's nice you're doing it
for us too cuz it makes us feel that way
too
tell me a little about shooting the
music video for rare tell me the kind of
every the behind the scenes so the video
for that was I had just recently gone to
Kenya and the nature there in the
appreciation for the animals it just
seemed so moving and so I wanted it to
feel like it was in nature and how
beautiful our world is and how it can be
and and then of course I wanted some
sort of mystical ethereal look so I
thought it came out together well well
it did mission accomplished
[Music]